So it's Thursday and we do have new jobs numbers,
another one point three million Americans
have filed first time unemployment claims,
meaning last week.
Remember this week we learned the numbers
from last week.
Another one point three million Americans
have lost their jobs.
Are you becoming numb to these numbers to
some degree?
I mean, I want to remind you, before the 15
week weeks in a row of corona virus job losses,
the previous single day record for new unemployment
claims was about 700000.
We've had as many as six point six million
in one week and continue to have right under
one point five million per week for several
weeks now.
And the reason that this week is particularly
important is that today we got the numbers
from last week.
In the last week, we have seen states have
to sort of re shut down elements of the economy.
That's happening this week, meaning next week
and the week after.
Are going to be crucial weeks in seeing whether
these numbers start to go up again.
The rate at which Americans have been losing
their jobs has been coming down.
We're still seeing people lose jobs, but we
had six point six million one week and then
five million, four million, etc.
The rate has been coming down.
Things are reclose thing, though, and the
next two weeks could be particularly ugly.
Last week was more of a normal week, you might
say, as normal as things can be during a pandemic.
And one point three million more people lost
their jobs.
So that's now fifteen straight weeks of job
losses.
That's a total of 51 million jobless claims
since Corona virus started.
Now, I know people e-mail me as if I'm trying
to deceive.
I'm mentioning we don't have 51 million people
out of work right now.
So 51 million people at some point lost their
jobs during the last 15 weeks.
Many millions of those have either gone back
to work or found new jobs.
So of the 51 million.
Only about 18 million remain actively unemployed
right now.
And that's obviously far better than 51 million,
although still historically high.
So now the question is, what happens next
week?
Corona virus has forced California to reclose
sectors of its economy.
Indoor dining is done.
Movie theater, a whole bunch of stuff that
had been open is now closing.
I won't give you the full list of states,
but there are many that are having to go backwards
in terms of opening.
Even Texas is is actually having to step back.
So this week, which will be reported next
week and also the following week, are going
to be very, very important.
Now, the other thing that's upcoming and I
want to remind you about it is that on July
30th, we're going to get the first estimate
of second quarter GDP.
Second quarter GDP has been widely expected
by both the left and the right to be maybe
the worst economic quarter for the United
States.
Possibly, ever, possibly.
We might get the worst GDP number in 14 days
that we have ever seen in the United States.
The second quarter, of course, was April,
May, June.
At the end of June, some stuff was starting
to reopen.
A lot of the opening has happened in July.
So at the end of this month, we're going to
get an estimate of just how bad was second
quarter GDP.
I don't know how bad it's going to be.
The expectation is that it's going to be quite
bad.
And sometimes when you get a bad number, that's
slightly better than what was expected.
It actually feels like, hey, we actually got
off less seriously than than we might have.
So I don't know what the answer is going to
be.
But in terms of the timing, July 30th, we're
going to get an estimate of Q2 GDP.
August 30th is when we'll get a more fine
tuned number.
And that is going to be very, very close to
the election of either Joe Biden or Donald
Trump for another four years.
And this is exactly as we've been predicting
for a couple of months.
Case is going up.
Q to GDP number is going to be dropped on
top of us sometime in the next two to six
weeks with different specificity and precision
as we get more accurate numbers by August
30th.
We are going to have dramatically more information
than we have right now about what the end
of the year and early 2021 is likely to be
for the United States.
We may also have some vaccine news.
We may also have news about therapeutics.
So in my mind, I'm sorry.
You know, I have a question on Friday's show
this week about where do I believe the point
of no return is for Donald Trump in terms
of if he doesn't turn his polling around and
I'm going to make the case that it's October
1st.
However, I'm seeing September 1st as a date,
at which point we are likely to have a lot
of additional important information about
how things are going.
Economic data, case data and much, much more.